and in his previous appearance how about
this set a national league record he's
allowed three or fewer earned runs in
his first 19 career starts if he could
do it two more times he'll set the major
league record
or at least tie the major league record
one thing he has working in his favor
tonight none of these oakland a's
hitters has ever seen zack now chapman
got off to a slow start offensively was
down under 200 the first week of august
but he has picked up the pace and then
some re-ensued chapman weights and the
delivery to matt is a little check swing
dribbler to the shortstop charging in
the shift martay throws to first and
just in time a good play by catelyn
martin who has played a lot of shortstop
and cutting in front of the shortstop
ahmed and chapman is out for three as
the a's go down one two three fifth
start for the right-hander 2-0 off to a
very good start a couple of home runs
allowed that was in his last start
against the angels trout and rindon
as they hit home runs against everybody
here's starling marte the longtime
pirate
here comes the 3-2 to starling and he
walked him outside soy two-hour walk for
batson that'll get peralta in the back
so the diamondbacks have the only base
runners a walk in the first
single leading off the second escobar
the big home run yesterday in the eighth
inning
punches that one the other way for
grossman
loses the glove it's in the corner
walker's on the run headed for third
they'll stop from there
and it's a double some fogo power for
eduardo escobar bassett walking the high
wire here had second and third nobody
out but he's got two big strikeouts and
now he'll deal with nick ahmed here's
the 3-2 and that's a fastball outside he
walked him now he's got calhoun with the
bases loaded well nicely back by nick
even one of those strikes wasn't really
a strike was called
so he worked pretty good count there and
you know he gets a big opportunity here
for cole calhoun allen left-handed
hitter gallon trying to go perfect
through three innings
here's a 2-2 and allen strikes out
swinging three strikeouts
among the nine retired in order
by zach gallon through three innings
we'll go to the bottom of the third here
in phoenix brought a strikeout on a
check swing two on the first
swings and hits one to right
and back she goes one-nothing
diamondbacks on david peralta's home run
his second of the season wow that ball's
crushed it looked like it was a slider
down and then he just dropped the head
of the pad on it and just rushed that
thing out of here there he is remaining
hot
gallon back to work now top of the order
starting with marcus simeon here comes a
3-2 and a change-up and a good take so
there's some intel there the aizen
noticed earlier that gallon would go to
that pitch to strike out somebody 3-2 he
did it on biscotti he did it on allen he
did it on olson as well this is biscotti
you strike out his first time up gallons
only at 62 pitches as he works with two
outs in the fifth
3-2 pitch coming up from gallon to
piscotty got him swinging tied him up
inside with the heater fifth strikeout
two of the inning for gallon ace go one
two three and they're still hitless just
one base runner tonight for the
athletics simeon walking leading off in
the fourth zach gallon looking to begin
his career by throwing 20 consecutive
starts giving up three runs or fewer
that's going to break up the no-hitter
austin allen down the line in the right
field corner and it's a one-out single
well here is maybe the biggest at-bat to
this point in the ball game for zach
allen two on and two out the dangerous
matt chapman the number three hitter the
2-2 pitch with two on and two out got
him swinging
gallon strikes out kemp and chapman with
two on and one out
seven strikeouts now for the
right-hander escobar a double and a
ground out one for two
here comes peralta kemp coming home and
david is in there rbi for escobar
two-nothing diamondbacks another contact
play that produces a run the idea is
it's going to take a perfect throw to
get him and that time tony kemp was not
able to make a perfect throw the infield
once again comes in for oakland escobar
third one out
high bouncer and throw into center
escobar is home carson kelly the rbi and
it's a three-nothing d-backs lead
allen winds the righties 1-0 and that is
pulled deep right center field calhoun
and marte giving chase toward the pool
and it is gone robbie grossman hits it
out as fourth of the year awakens the
a's offense they finally strike on
gallon and trail three to one so rondon
has come on to relieve zach gallon to
start the eighth inning and loaded the
bases with one out holding a two run
base is loaded 2-0 delivery is swung on
lifted right field calhoun going back in
the corner has a play in fair territory
makes the catch that a score of the run
machine scores barretto tags he goes
from second to third holding it first is
kemp but now it's a one-run game
it's down by a run two out top half of
the eighth here's the stretch in the 2-1
pitch on the way is a fly ball short
left field going out from short ahmed he
can't make the play he misplayed it
scoring from third is barretto and the
ace tie it up starling will walk to
first base with the intentional walk and
peralta has gone two for four tonight
with a home run and a double will come
up trying to win it
diamondbacks walk it off david peralta
the freight train wins it and the
diamondbacks get over 500 they've won
five in a row yeah